going back on the topic of watching
stuff though um so
as i have been watching anime again
um
i wanted to know if you have had the
same experience where do the subtitles
actively distract you now from like
what's going on in english yeah if you
have english subtitles on
sometimes i can turn off the brain part
the part of my brain that's trying to
listen to the japanese yeah i can just
ignore that because like i yeah because
like i this was the first time i started
watching anime for my video and of
course i turned on subtitles because i
had to understand what's going on yeah
because i've been watching anime
as for like a long period of time
without subtitles and it was so weird
turning it back on because it like
actively
i i actually dislike it now it actively
distracts me from what's going on
any anime with subtitles now i'm trying
not to you have become next level
i'm i'm like trying to watch as much
anime without subtle subtitles on as i
can because like what i've realized is
that it actually it actively hurts your
language learning process if you have
english subtitles on well or at least
here's here's the way to understand yeah
here's the way i see it right because
say you have like a japanese sentence or
hear a japanese sentence and you want
the english translation of that
if the if the translator for the
subtitle is doing their job
they would have translated what they're
saying into natural english so that it
sounds natural yes whereas when i'm when
i'm trying to learn japanese and i'm
trying to process the japanese in my
head
what i've read in the subtitles and
what's being said are like are the same
things but it's different like i would
actually like i realized this where i
think it would be more useful for me
if i had google translated subtitles
then an actual like professionally
translated subtitle right because
because when i'm going back and i'm
trying to understand something and i
read the official translation i'm just
like well yeah that and i you know i do
my work to translate it i'm like yeah
that's what's being said but that's not
how i think about that sentence being
heard in my brain but that's also like
the problem right is that i think at the
end of the day like so much of it is
nuanced because grammatically it's just
so different yeah a lot of it is just
completely i've read some subtitles
where it's just been completely lost in
translation because there are just some
things
some phrases and ways of saying a
sentence and the way of describing
something that is so specifically
japanese yeah that if the sub if the
translator tries to translate it without
the translator notes
to explain it yeah then it just becomes
like
it becomes so nuanced to the point that
it almost becomes like a subjective
translation where it's like i personally
think this is what they're trying to say
but it's not true 100 the same and i
feel that if people try and use that
as a way to learn grammar yeah then
they're going to get one nuanced way of
learning it which is not exactly
accurate yeah when i was watching the
american films obviously in japan yeah
they have the japanese subtitles yeah
interesting
yeah it is it is it is i'm like oh that
would be like a really heavy amount of
slang yeah i'll just translate it into
something extremely simple and mundane
that doesn't really convey the situation
well i don't think it does yeah uh but
obviously it works other way around as
well but like i watch i watch uh
actually you know it's quite helpful
watching japanese tv because they have
subtitles in japanese on the screen
every goddamn two seconds rip editors
but
yeah they have the subtitles on the
screen and i find it way easier
to watch japanese stuff with japanese
subtitles yeah because i know i know a
fair amount of kanji like basic stuff so
i can normally kind of it really helps
me
solidify
the sentence because often i just i'm
just in taking and i don't see anything
to kind of like
lay it out and when i when i'm hearing
stuff and i can see the line
i can kind of be like oh that's what
he's saying because there's some words
that can mean like you know uh like
you and you say tara like
such
but then like tara can mean like so many
different things in so many different
contexts right if when it can be like
advice right it could be like a
recommendation of like oh you should do
this right so
it's really confusing because sometimes
if you stop paying attention for one
second and then you hear something like
tara and then you still you're like
trying to you're panicking to figure out
what way they're using this word yeah
that could mean so many things
and so it's really confusing but then
having the subtitles in japanese oh okay
well i just saw the first part and i
glanced at the second part i can figure
out what's going on i think every
language is like that though like even
in english right where it's like the
word of for instance
it can mean a million different things
depending on the sentence right and
japanese i think it's just like a little
more difficult because
you know it again like unlike in english
where there is spaces between words that
clearly distinguish between what this
word means versus what this next word
means in japanese we don't have that
it's just
continuous flow i remember the first
time i saw like you know i opened like a
japanese light novel or something and
i'm just like this [ __ ] terrifies me
it's it's just they're like
it's just one continuous line of text
i'm just like
what's that yeah the only thing that
stops it is a comma or a period yeah
right everything else is just
nonstop
and i never thought i could get
terrified by like just letters before
until i opened like a japanese novel i
was like this this is just this is just
one line this is just yeah where's the
separation come on guys i feel like this
is a very small nitpick you know how
cause obviously in japanese right the
subject comes first yeah so more often
than not when they're like explaining
like plot twists and anime it's so hard
to like hype it up because the subject
comes first yeah so it's like
gand was the killer killer or something
it's not like and the killer was
can't it's always like
no actually in japanese we can do that
yeah okay yeah we can do that where like
you know for example like uh like murder
mystery stories in japanese do this a
lot okay like you know normally if if
someone were to say like you're the
culprit right in english we can do the
same thing right you can say the culprit
is you or
you're the culprit right like same thing
in japanese you could say it gives a
taste so like you know uh like if i were
to say
you're the culprit right in that order
then it'll be hanyu
oh yeah
versus
which is you're the culprit which one
sounds more natural though because like
they're both natural okay because what i
noticed about english is that you know
it's just us in japanese
sorry sorry
no but what i've noticed is that you
know with the translation it with
translating the japanese like natural
english or yes some english that reads
naturally like sometimes you can get the
same meaning across in english it just
sounds really jank you know especially
with how the sentence structure and
japanese grammar is right it turns out
languages are like nothing alike
not yeah language is like english